so you know I'm really fascinated by the
debate that has been raging these past
several days among conservatives around
the issue of pornography and I'm happy
to accept part of the blame for helping
to start this this little scuffle
because I think that it's been a
clarifying moment for conservatism I
think it's been very interesting
conversation as well and there was an
article in Vox written by Jane Koston
who and she she called me up and talked
to me before writing the article as well
to get my thoughts on I thought she did
it's actually very objective and fair
and insightful so I'd recommend that you
go check it out
but as she you know talking to both
sides of the conservative divide on this
as she as she outlines the dispute over
porn regulation really Springs from a
more fundamental disagreement about the
purpose and the nature of government and
so different conservatives have come
down to different sides sides of this
guys like Sarah boom ari have come down
on the pro regulation side while the
libertarians over reason have
unsurprisingly come down on the other
side and then also as I'm sure probably
you've noticed if you if you watch all
the shows and you follow everybody here
at the Daily wire you've noticed that
the dividing line on this issue runs
right through the Daily wire as well so
Michael Knowles and Josh hammer are also
on on of the view that government has a
legitimate role in battling the porn
epidemic and then you've got ben shapiro
and the god-king jeremy boring say that
you know it should not have a
substantial role and that any role if
there is one should not be an outright
ban so i don't want to say that their
position is that the government has no
role at all i don't think that is their
position but certainly they don't agree
with an outright ban they don't think it
seems to me they don't think there
should be a substantial significant role
by the government in regulating this
stuff now i think every everybody who's
chimed in has contributed thoughtfully
to the discussion and i'm not just
saying that because two of them signed
my page
I think actually think that everyone's
been very thoughtful about it but
through this whole back and forth and
and this is why I wanted says we we
started the week talking about this and
it's been a running thread throughout
the week and now we're at the end of the
week so I figured let's put a let's put
a capstone on the week at least for me
on this issue and and putting a capstone
on what I would really like to do is try
to bring the conversation back to what I
think is when it comes to pornography
the central point now there is a broader
more philosophical point that we've been
talking about but I want to bring it
back to what I think is the central
point when it comes to pornography
specifically and what I also think is
Mott is it is my strongest argument so
putting aside for a moment the
philosophical discussion about the
nature of government the state's role in
preserving the common good which is an
important conversation also again I
think a really interesting one but it
leads us far into the weeds and I think
we lose sight of the original subject
that we're supposed to be talking about
and so that's why I wanted to
re-emphasize a very simple point that
I've made about the porn problem I want
to go back to it because everybody
that's chimed in on this I if they if
they have I haven't heard it but I have
not heard anyone address this point that
I'm about to make and that I've already
made several times and that I think has
been lost in the whole does government
protect the common good or is about
preserving Liberty are those the same
things are they not all of that the
defense of pornography or at least of
its from of its remaining legal and
mostly unregulated seems to hinge on the
fact the alleged fact that the content
in pornography is produced and viewed by
consenting adults right if viewers do
not consent to viewing a sexual act then
we all probably agree that a crime has
occurred so I think even on the far
reaches of extreme libertarianism I
don't think you're gonna find very many
people who say that you have a right to
have an orgy on the subway okay
porn is different it's argued because
you only view it if you seek it out if
viewers of porn were not consenting if
internet porn let's just say or of such
a nature that millions of people were
forced to watch it against their will
every year then it would seem that the
argument against prohibition or
regulation starts to crumble so that the
the argument the argument against my
point
and Michael Noel's point josh hammers
point no Mary's point I think the
argument really hinges on this this this
concept of consent you take that out and
I think the opposition argument really
falls apart well I think that that's
that it has fallen fallen apart I think
the argument has already crumbled
because indeed millions of people are
exposed to it every year against their
will against their consent and I think
those who are defending the legality of
porn seem to be ignoring this group and
this argument and that to me seems like
an insurmountable moral and logical flaw
in their position children okay that's
what I think this we got to bring this
back to that for me is as I said the
central point here children are first
exposed to porn at the age of 11 on
average so as we speak right now there
are no doubt millions of minors some of
them as young as five or six watching
adults have sex on the internet this is
an indisputable fact okay that's how
large the numbers are you have millions
of kids watching this stuff I think
anyone would deny that but does that
fact not really destroy the consent
excuse offered by the other side because
our legal system rests on the assumption
that minors can not consent to engage in
sexual acts and not now that they don't
that they can't by their nature if an
adult has sex with a child the adult is
guilty of rape no matter if the child
verbally agreed to it or not in our
society we understand that
children lack the mental and emotional
faculties to consent they cannot consent
to deny that is to literally defend
pedophilia
well if children cannot consent to
engage in a sexual act does it not
inevitably follow that they cannot
consent to witness such an act if they
cannot consent as a second party
participant does it not follow that they
cannot consent as a third-party
participant and in pornography the
viewer is the third-party participant
thus if my logic is correct here and I
think it is I think I think I'm drawing
I'm connecting the dots pretty pretty
logically here so that means that every
child who watches porn does so by
definition without consent I don't see
how you can quibble with this argument
without also quibbling with the logic
for criminalizing pedophilic behavior
now I'm not saying that the people on
the opposite side of this issue are
trying to legalize pedophilia I'm not
saying that I'm saying that they fail to
appreciate how our laws against
pedophilia already provide a basis for
pornography regulation that's my point
this all means that every consenting
adult who posts hardcore sex videos to
the Internet does so knowing that
children can very easily access it and
view it they are putting it as it were
within reach of a child if the child
reaches for it who do we blame is it the
child's fault or the fault of the person
who put it there I would argue that
every child who has viewed internet
pornography is a victim of abuse and the
abuser is the person who posted the
content where a child with no trouble at
all could find it now it's it's even
more it's even more serious than this
because the internet porn industry makes
hundreds of millions of dollars a year
on children each hit to a site like
pornhub is monetized and we know
the numbers show that millions of
children are looking at porn so millions
of children minors kids that are 8 9 10
11 12 13 14 they are going to that site
just focusing on porn up for a moment
pornhub is monetizing those hits so
pornhub this is inescapable
pornhub is making millions of dollars
off of showing porn to kids if you don't
think the government has an interest in
protecting the common good broadly
speaking will you admit that it at least
has an interest in preventing people
from making millions on providing
pornography to 12 year olds I mean can
you at least acknowledge that can you at
least entertain the possibility that
maybe the government could have some
interest there and there is not there
just there is nothing if pornhub you all
you do is just go to pornhub and that's
it and you got to click little things as
are you 18 that's it that's the whole
okay that's that's that's the whole
that's that's all that's all the
protection that are put in place
shouldn't at least be a lot more than
that in terms of protection and when you
get into all the what about alcohol what
about cigarettes what about this that
yeah all of that stuff there's much more
regulation and protection and yes kids
still can can get their hands on it but
there is much more there are many more
protections put in place for all of that
now the obvious dodged here as I've as
I've been trying to tackle all week is
to lay the blame at the feet of the
parents and it and I really and I get
you know I know the argument you'll say
well it's not the pornographers fault
it's up to the parents to stop their
kids from seeing this stuff I just I I
think that this rejoinder is very lazy
and I also speculate that a good number
of the people making this argument
either aren't parents or you know they
had young kids a long time ago before
the internet was really a problem I just
I think that if you are a parent of a
you know 11 12 13 year old kid
you probably have a greater appreciation
than a lot of people seem to have for
how overly simplistic that argument is
now it's true that parents should be
doing everything they can to shield
their children from the filth on the
internet but it's also true that the
Internet is ubiquitous and parents
cannot on their own do a sufficient job
in shielding their kids from it they
just can't it's not that they won't or
that they they don't feel like it it is
they can't that's the reality that's the
reality of the society we live in if the
child has no phone no internet access at
home I mean you're going as Extreme as
you possibly can which isn't even that
extreme but these days I mean having no
internet at home that's that's pretty
extreme and in terms of protecting your
kid from from Internet poor that's
that's that's what else can you do
that's that's as far as you could
possibly go but let's say that you go as
far as you could possibly go well he can
still go almost anywhere and access the
Internet dozens of different ways so
short of moving into a cave in the
desert which maybe isn't such a bad idea
but short of that a parent can only
provide partial cover but partial cover
in the end is only a little better than
no cover at all besides none of this
does anything to relieve the
responsibility of the person posting the
content in the first place even if every
child exposed to porn has ineffectual
and inattentive and lazy and bad parents
which most emphatically is not the case
but even if it was that still does not
explain why anyone should have the right
to post sex videos on a public forum
where children can easily access them we
can talk about parents parents that
doesn't well what about this let's look
at an adult okay forget about the
parents for a second let's think here
about an adult who has a sex video a
depraved graphic sex video and he is now
making the choice to upload this to the
internet send it out into the world for
anyone to see what about him
does he have no responsibility what is
he some kind of animal he can't control
himself well you're really gonna put all
of the responsibility on the parents
none on this creep at all none on this
scumbag who's putting this on the
internet for it I mean just
here you go anyone that wants to see it
so your tell you no responsibility for
that guy all on the parents I mean that
that's the feedback I'm getting is that
we're not no we're not even focused on
that guy at all is that he can do
whatever he wants I find that to be so
morally obtuse that position that IIIi
it's I can't it I have trouble believing
that anyone really thinks that you know
we'd let's talk about children that are
that are physically abused that are
molested you know it's probably true
that that some children who are molested
some could have been saved from that
trauma had their parents been more
vigilant but that does nothing to excuse
the man who did the molesting me think
about the were the worst pedophile in
American history was was a pediatrician
in Delaware this was not as only a few
years ago abused hundreds of young kids
and kids as young as I mean we're
talking babies to toddlers okay how was
he able to do that in the in the
doctor's office well parents would send
their kids back there two or three year
old kid back with this monster who they
didn't know was a monster but but still
they would send their kids back with the
doctor alone now most parents know you
never leave your child alone with a
doctor I mean you should be in the room
if the doctors telling you leave the
room then that's it red flags all over
the place okay unless unless this is a
surgery and they're putting the kid
under for some kind of serious surgery
obviously you got to leave the room but
then but then even in that case it's not
gonna just be one person in the room
with an unconscious child right but so
so you know the the parents who allow
their their kids to go back with this
this scumbag this monster this animal
they were tragically not as vigilant as
they should have been but but here's my
point that the blame still is not on the
parents okay
who have to live with this for the rest
of their lives as well the blame is not
on the parents there are also victims
the blame is on the the the scumbag
monstrous despicable human garbage that
did this he's the guy who did it
it's his blame so what I'm saying is and
I'm not drawing a direct moral
comparison not saying that someone
uploads a sex video to the Internet is
exactly like the serial you know the the
worst serial pedophile in history I'm
not saying that I'm trying to make a
point about responsibility and so when
you make that choice to upload that
content to the Internet knowing that
anyone can see it you're not an idiot
you know that kids are all over the
Internet and they will be able to view
it and not only that but you're gonna
profit if your pornhub you're gonna
profit off of that viewership so I say
all the responsibility really is on you
all of it
how could it not be so the question is
this do we have a natural human right
and I want you to focus don't focus on
the viewers here for a moment
focus on the people who distribute this
content to put the content on the
Internet these are the pornographers so
be a pornographer these days it doesn't
just mean you work for a you know a
studio that does pornography films and
you're a director or something you're a
pornographer if you if you worked at
pornhub you're a pornographer because
you're distributing this content so
let's focus on the people distributing
it do they have a natural human right to
post hardcore sex videos online where
children can see them is that a natural
human right would you say is that is
that something intrinsic to their human
nature just you take that ability away
and they're not able to live a
fulfilling human life anymore is that
was it I mean is it something just
utterly essential to - to your nature as
a human to be able to do this would
anyone argue that let me anyone who says
yes has an extremely confused and
hopelessly ambiguous conception of human
rights but I think rational people will
say no and but the people
who say no must then way whether a
person's privileged to post this kind of
content on the internet outweighs the
right of a child to be free from sexual
abuse and trauma so this does not have
to be a debate about philosophies of
governance and so on this can be much
simpler you do not have a right to
expose children to sexually explicit
content you just you don't have that
right you don't have a right to do it
children do have a right to be to to
certain basic legal protections I think
that fact alone in my view settles the
argument and I would be really
interested in someone engaging with that
specific argument that I just have laid
out now by the way when I made this
argument I my piece yesterday just to
anticipate some of the objections I
brought a piece yesterday making the
same argument and a bunch of people
countered that well you know if a child
a child seeing porn if that's
automatically abuse I mean if a child is
an abuse victim for seeing porn then
what about a child who walks into the
bedroom while his parents are having sex
this now maybe you hear that that
response and you think well that's
really stupid and it is but a lot of
people that was their immediate response
so I feel like I have to address it and
this is what porn defenders always seem
to do this seems to be the only trick in
their bag is to draw these equivalencies
obviously there's a difference for one
thing with what a what a child briefly
witnesses when he walks into a bedroom
at night before presumably his parents
immediately usher him out what he
witnesses will will not really be the
same as what he will witness if he sits
on pornhub
for a few minutes okay also there's the
matter of intent a private act that is
meant to be private and then is
accidentally witnessed by someone is
very different from an act that is
broadcast on the Internet to a potential
audience of millions obviously those are
two different things
and there's a difference in kind also if
a child walks in on his parents that's
awkward that's embarrassing that's not
what you want but what he has witnessed
what he has unfortunately witnessed is
still the healthy and properly ordered
expression of love and devotion between
two married people you definitely would
prefer for him not to witness it if
you're the parents but if he does the
parents can explain they can have the
awkward birds in the bees conversation
and they can explain that when a man
loves a woman they get together they get
married etc and so forth what he will
see in a porn film though is a woman
being used integrated for the pleasure
of anonymous by standards by standards
that that again is very very very
different another people think people
have countered with is well what about
other bad stuff kids might see online
what about what about vulgar violent
content hateful content graphic
graphically violent content and as to
that well as to that sort of stuff it
kind of depends on what it is because
there's other yeah there is other kind
there are other kinds of really
disturbing SiC content online that
should be illegal and oftentimes is and
we'll get to that in a second but this
whole what about thing is so weak
because it would be kind of like if I
said it should be illegal for a parent
to punch a child in the face okay which
it is obviously but what if it wasn't
and then I were to argue that it should
be and then you go and you say well wait
a minute but what about a parent who
smacks a child in the back of the head
and then it's like yeah well that that's
I mean that's probably abuse too but it
may be it depends a little bit on
context is this a dad with his teenage
son he's kind of horsing around and you
know it doesn't just kind of joking
around a little is it that or is this is
this a toddler being smack in the back
of the head and anger
by a parent those are two very different
things so it might depend and then and
then you go well okay but what about
what about someone who's a child who's
spanked very hard with a belt and again
it's just what you're doing is you keep
coming with these what about sand
what-ifs and hypotheticals and you're
dragging the conversation further and
further and further into the gray area
but remember where we started we started
with something that is obviously bad and
should obviously be illegal now if you
keep going further and further down into
the gray areas into the fine
distinctions and all this stuff it's
gonna be harder and harder to draw those
lines yes but we started with something
that is very obvious I mean with that we
all in fact would agree is bad and
terrible and should be illegal apparent
punching a child in the face and but
what you've done is you've seemingly
intentionally prevented us from
addressing that issue by trying to make
it seem like physical abuse itself is so
ambiguous and so hard to legislate that
there's just no point in punishing or
prohibiting prohibiting it in any form
whatsoever you've tried to water down
the discussion order in order to stop us
from from talking about a very obvious
and clear-cut form of abuse okay so any
any of the what about you can draw here
that does nothing to address what porn
is and it is something that is damaging
and traumatic and harmful to kids
there's no getting around that is there
other stuff in that category
maybe but can we talk about this
category first and if there is other
stuff that should also be addressed does
that does that mean we can't address
this why are you so afraid to have this
conversation
and speaking of the other kinds of
content that are illegal in fact someone
brought this up yesterday I don't
remember if it was on Twitter or or I
don't remember where it maybe was in a
comment section email huko it's all it's
all blurred together but somebody said
well what about you know there's so many
other horrible things
what about crushing videos animal
crushing videos now I don't know if
you're familiar with animal crushing
videos if you aren't I'm sorry I have to
tell you about them
but they are a form of video and there's
a lot of them apparently online there's
though there's a whole deranged sick
community of people who post this stuff
and it it's exactly what it sounds like
it's videos of animals being crushed or
otherwise tortured and killed and these
videos are post online people watch them
and because they get some kind of sick
enjoyment out of it so someone brought
that up to me said what about the
crushing and to that I say yeah okay now
here we go
yes I would say that is definitely as
harmful to watch if not more so I mean
now it kind of depends away but but that
is definitely at least in the same
category but here's the thing those
videos are illegal in fact it just so
happens that they were very recently
made illegal on the federal level Donald
Trump just signed something into law
making it illegal to distribute and
there were other things involved in this
law too it wasn't just targeted and
animal crushing videos but that was
included it is now illegal on the
federal level as I understand the law to
distribute post distribute whatever
these animal crushing videos it's
illegal now that's very interesting
isn't it because now it you could easily
say well that's totally different
because you're torturing and killing an
animal and so something is being killed
that's different from pornography which
again it's it's not always different
from pornography because very often in
many cases you have trafficked women and
children who are in these videos and
and you may not know it as the viewer so
there is torture and torment going on in
these videos as well but leaving that
aside the point is it's not it's not it
wasn't made illegal to record the videos
that was already illegal obviously
obviously it's illegal to torture an
animal so I was already illegal the
question is once that's happened and
there's footage of it and the footage is
out there I mean unfortunately the
animals already dead so sharing the
video is not gonna hurt the animal the
animals already been killed technically
that video itself doesn't hurt anybody
its footage of something being hurt but
the video doesn't hurt anybody what the
law says now is that you even if you
weren't the one who did that you still
cannot distribute this video so if
someone were to send me a whole load of
files of animal crushing videos I didn't
I didn't hurt the animals the person who
sent the videos didn't hurt the animals
the person that he got the videos from
didn't hurt the animals I mean down the
line we could work 20 50 100 steps
removed a million steps removed who
knows but I have these videos now I
cannot post them online and I shouldn't
be able to in my opinion but I wonder if
you're you know a defender of the
legality of porn how do you deal with
that because if you're saying that
pornography is and please I would ask
you to deal with it
aside from just scoffing look that's
totally different so stupid well it's
not totally different there there are
some similarities here that I think you
have to deal with one is the issue of
speech I mean if pornography is speech
then why isn't this speech again not the
act but what about why is it not speech
for me to distribute these videos maybe
there's a message I'm trying to send
that'll be a message you like but I mean
aren't a my not expressing myself in
some way with this video I mean if
that's if that's not free speech if that
doesn't count as speech if you're not
gonna buy that that is expression then
why would a you know a porn video a rape
porn video even if everyone's acting and
it's not really rape but but why is that
expression
so I think it touches on the on the
speech issue it also touches on the
issue of of the effect of viewing
content what exactly is the problem with
having videos of animal crutch crushing
an animal torture all over the Internet
what's the problem what's problem with
having kids view it I mean again the the
the being that was unfortunately hurt is
already dead is not cannot continue to
be hurt by it so that's already done and
over with so what's the harm I mean do
you think that a child is gonna watch a
video like that and immediately go out
and kill his dog maybe but probably not
that directly but no we're okay with
those videos being illegal I assume
you're probably okay with it I certainly
am we're okay with it because number one
it's just depraved and horrible and ugly
and wrong and just intrinsically evil
number two the the the traumatic effect
it would have on on the viewer
especially children traumatized by it
but also the influence it will have on
them probably you know if a kids exposed
to that video one time he's probably not
gonna go out and kill his dog but if he
if he watches that stuff enough and
starts to find it appealing for some
reason yeah I think he is gonna be
influenced obviously got clearly he's
gonna be influenced even if he never
actually hurts an animal he's going to
be influenced in that direction what
about all these videos online and some
of the most popular search terms for
pornography part of things like rape
incest teenager and yeah these videos
the legal ones anyway are it's just
pretend okay it's not really incest
they're just they're actors maybe that's
not really a fifteen-year-old it's just
it's just someone who looks 15 but what
is the effect okay you watch animal
crushing videos enough you might be
inclined to eventually go and and and
mistreat an animal I think we all
understand that you watch these kinds of
videos enough isn't that not going to
sway you is that not going to influence
you towards maybe being inclined to act
out these things that you already
obviously
appealing and you have been feeding that
dark part of your soul and your mind
okay so switching gears here for a
minute
it's switching gears a little bit
actually because I think this sort of
relates to the some of what we've been
talking about this week but there's this
video that's been going around online
maybe you've seen it it's from campus
reform another other classic you know
interviewing clueless students on the
street bit those are always fun but this
one there the students are asked if they
support Medicare for all and then they
all say yes of course and then there and
then and then we find out if they still
support it once they discover what's
actually in that bill what it actually
entails so let's uh let's watch a little
bit of this the policy right now they're
proposing it's Medicare for all which is
you know the idea of government-funded
health care for everyone is that a
concept you view favorably or
unfavorably favorably for sure
I do support Medicare for all I do I do
think that every American deserves
health care
I do support that I think it's an
important form of universal health care
I do support free health care for
everybody in general I would say yes I
do favor Medicare I don't think there's
anything that you could really tell me
that would make me of you unfavorably
gonna give you a few of those things I
want to see if you view them favorably
or unfavorably within the plan and just
see if it changes your opinion at all so
first off it is mandatory so it would be
over 100 million people right now have
private insurance plans that they like
they would be removed from those plans
by the government would be mandatory and
they would be put on the government plan
even if they didn't want to is that
something that concerns you at all
probably yeah do you do that element
favorably or unfavorably I think I would
say unfavorably for that unfavorably I
mean they shouldn't be like kicked off
of it I guess
that doesn't seem fair I would say the
government can't force them to have
health care with them and they're just
like that's what this would do yeah I
definitely think everyone should have
health care but I think those who are
able to get private health care don't
necessarily like shouldn't have to
necessarily be removed from it I mean as
a Bernie support I think you do have to
give up some choice just for the benefit
of everyone in society so the second
part it would eliminate private health
insurance the entire industry it would
be just under a million jobs would be
eliminated because all insurance moved
to the government okay very inspiring
gives you a lot of hope for the future
of our country doesn't it so so how do
how does this relate to our discussion
this week well I think it relates this
way because what you find is that these
students initially support Medicare for
all because they find the moral argument
for it appealing and that's and that's
how it's sold to them you know and
that's how the left sells all of its
policy ideas morally so you heard the
first student say something like people
deserve it or some of them something
along those lines which is a moral
statement talking about what people
deserve then it all starts to fall apart
not when they're told about the
financial cost although that does come
later in the video when they discover
that the Free Medicare isn't actually
free because the taxpayers have to pay
for it turns out nothing is free in life
I guess their dad's never told them that
they never gave them the old money
doesn't grow on trees stick but I think
you see their dreams for Medicare for
all start to die in their eyes start to
fade a little bit when they're presented
with a fuller view of its moral
implications people will be forced off
of their private plans people will lose
their jobs now there are economic issues
there as well but mainly I think for
these liberal students it's the moral
problem and so this is just a small
example but it's very important and I've
been saying that's not just this week
but for years that the the left makes
moral arguments for all of their
positions all of it our policy ideas all
the laws and legislation they support
everything they always make those
arguments
on a moral basis just pay attention next
time you hear a leftist whoever it is a
Ossie Bernie Sanders what Elizabeth
Warren I mean listen to the to the
Democratic debates every argument they
make is is moral in its character
now when I say moral I don't mean
morally good I don't agree with their
arguments but they're of a moral
character they're making the argument
based on morality based on what they
believe what they are claiming is just
the right thing to do and that's how
they argue for everything it's not about
how much it's gonna cost not about it
it's not really about economy it's those
are a peripheral those are secondary
issues for them the way they present it
is listen this is just the right thing
to do and it's effective it's persuasive
maybe not to you maybe not to me but to
a lot of people it is especially people
in my generation and younger they find
it very persuasive because these are the
arguments they care about these are the
arguments everybody cares about when it
comes down to it nobody really cares
about any argument that isn't moral I
mean yeah you could talk about you could
start getting into the financials and
pull out the calculator and show how
this is gonna be more nobody I mean this
whole idea that people vote based on
their pocket book I don't know who came
up with that originally but it is such
nonsense people do not vote up vote on
their pocketbook or their wallet they
vote on morality that's how people vote
what drives you to the polls it's
because you you you think you're
standing for what's right or because
you're afraid of someone else who's
gonna do the wrong thing take America
down the wrong path the morally wrong
path to a dark and evil future right
that's what gets you there it's not
about that it's not it's not about the
money so what's happened is the left
they have hectored the right four years
saying you can't legislate morality you
can't legislate morality stop trying to
legislate morality and then but they
turn around and they make moral
arguments for everything so they say
don't legislate morality and then they
turn around and unabashedly try to
slate morality but the rights you know
you see we on the right wheat and and
I'm sorry this is the case but we tend
to be pretty gullible and clueless and
it takes us a long time apparently to
pick up on things and so we got suckered
into this where the left forces don't
legislate morality and eventually
conservatives said oh you're right yeah
no no we don't to do that now we won't
argue about morals anymore
no yeah let's not argue about that then
we went off over here and started
arguing about financials and everything
else while the left they cleared the
field they're sitting there saying you
stupid suckers I can't believe you fell
for that and now they just continue now
they make every argument on a moral
basis and they can say that look you see
those people over there they're not even
arguing for what's right they don't care
they just care about their money those
greedy Scrooge's you see what they did
they convinced us to vacate the moral
premises and make arguments on economy
or whatever else and while they
continued to make those arguments so
that we look like unfeeling sociopaths
and automatons and nobody is persuaded
nobody finds it compelling
no one cares we're not convincing
anybody I mean worse is when you run
into conservatives who are so I'm sorry
stupid that they think especially you
can't make moral arguments to young
people that's what they think they think
you think well you got to especially
stay away from that with young kid no
with young people you especially have to
make the moral arguments they're the
most persuaded by those when you're
young you're the most likely to be
idealistic you care about you know
fighting for what's right and you're
willing to make sacrifices but you just
you care more about that when you're
younger when you get older I think you
become a little bit more practical and
you start making compromises some of
them good and some of them bad you stop
caring as much about some of the you
start being you stop being as convicted
as you once were on moral issues I think
now that's not I don't think that's good
I don't think it should be that way but
that is how it kind of works but again
the left they they they suckered us they
fooled us they said oh no young people
don't care
that yeah talk to young people about tax
policy they're really gonna be they're
really gonna be convinced by that then
they start go laughing at us did you
hear them I just told him I just told
him to talk to young people about tax
policy and they believed it that's it
yes that's what's happening I mean we
need to we need to wake up and realize
[Music]
every all laws entail legislating
morality every law does but the left
knows that the only people who don't
know it anymore are conservatives when
it used to be that conservatives were
the ones pointing us out
it really is brilliant I mean you almost
have to respect it it's it's so
brilliant when you realize what the left
has done it is really genius the way
that over a few decades they have
convinced conservatives to completely
abandon their own principles and their
own position Wow incredible also very
depressing here's something that's not
depressing this holiday season do your
friends and family a solid by getting
them a daily wire gift membership and
the good news for you
from now till January 1st all insider
plus gift memberships will be twenty
five percent off that means your loved
one will get all the fantastic perks
plus the majestic glorious beautiful
profound leftist tears tumblr and you'll
get the savings that's 25 percent off
all the insider plus gift memberships
this holiday season go to daily wire.com
slash gift to get your twenty five
percent off again that's daily wire.com
slash gift get your twenty five percent
off just don't tell your loved ones that
you save twenty five percent on their
gift in fact tell them that it was
twenty five percent more that we charged
just on principle but you'll be giving
them a gift that they'll thank you for
all year long let's go to emails matt
wall show at gmail.com this is from
samantha says hi Matt big fan of the
show yesterday you talked about the new
baby it's cold outside I agree that that
song is horrid but also hilarious but it
doesn't hold a candle to Santa baby
which is the worst Christmas song ever
hands down Samantha I'm afraid you are
incorrect the worst Christmas song ever
hands down his wonderful Christmas time
by Paul McCartney there is nothing that
comes close to it this song is so bad
that every
think McCartney has done in his career
or ever accomplished is erased by it
none of that matters because he will
forever and always be the guy who made
the terrible redundant pointless empty
awful song that plays over the intercom
at the department store or every 12
minutes on the Christmas radio station
you know your local Christmas music
radio station I'll tell you what makes a
song so bad it's stupid and lazy
so other bad Christmas songs are just
stupid Santa baby is stupid
last Christmas is stupid but at least
they've got their own kind of vibe to
them their own sort of they they aren't
good but it sounds like maybe the people
involved put a little bit of effort into
it maybe wonderful Christmas time you
could tell the McCartney wrote it in 95
seconds scrawled it on a used paper
plate took another three minutes to come
up with a melody and that was it so just
I mean let's listen listen to the lyrics
I'm not gonna sing them but let's just
go think it helps sometimes to read them
like spoken word poetry the moon is
right the spirits up we're here tonight
and that's enough simply having a
wonderful christmas time simply having a
wonderful christmas time okay
what does that mean the moon is right
and who evolved the moon for Christmas
the imagery here is it's not even
relevant we're here tonight and that's
enough has never been a more obvious
throwaway line well there has been in
this song because every line is a
throwaway
he's just filling space he's biding his
time till he gets to the end of the song
the party's on the feelings here that
only comes this time of year simply
having a wonderful christmas time simply
having a wonderful christmas time aside
from wonderful christmas time has he
even said anything that has anything to
do with christmas and what is the
feelings here mean the feeling just
arrived to the party hey guys the
feelings finally here what took you so
long the choir of children's sing their
song they practice all year long ding
dong ding dong ding dong ding dong
simply having a wonderful christmas time
simply having a wonderful christmas time
i mean come on you you can tell exactly
what happened here he had one line in
mind for this verse that's all he could
come up with he could only think of one
line the choir chil
and sing their song could think of
anything else thought about it though
for 10 seconds and in fact it's not even
it's not obvious to me that Paul
McCartney even knows what Christmas is
do they have Christmas in England is
that the problem here I don't think he
knows what it is that's what I'm getting
from the lyrics he has no idea what this
thing is someone called him up and says
can he make a Christmas song and he said
at Christmas what I got Chris a
Christmas Chris Christmas and then he
said I don't know what that is but do
people have a wonderful time on it yeah
yeah they do okay I got it I got you
I'll call you back in five minutes so he
puts down choir you know choir sings the
song then he's like yeah choir sings a
song Carson so they practice all year
long and now we need another you know
needs another two he needs another two
lines to fill out the verse and sorry so
he thinks it's practice all your law
that's in the song dingdong dingdong
dingdong dingdong the word is out about
the town to lift a glass and don't look
down don't what well now he's given up
okay this at the end he's given up it's
actually very depressing morbid song
because at the end he's given up on
music he's given off giving up on
himself he's given up on life it was
this verse the word is out around the
town what word the word that Christmas
that's Christmastime
I think people are calling it hey guys
you know crisp it's Christmastime did
you guys know that lift the glass and
don't look down well what do you mean
don't look down at the glass he needs
but he needs a he needs a word that
rhymes with town and so he says well
town down Brown now down down yeah don't
look down don't look down that's it yeah
we'll go with that simply having a
wonderful christmas time simply having a
wonderful christmas time simply having a
wonderful christmas time simply having a
wonderful christmas time again take the
chorus out and you have no clue this is
a christmas song there is no Christmas
imagery at all in this song honey I'm
not even asking for religious content
that's not my point okay I know he's not
going to start talking about the
christ-child but I mean no sleigh bells
no eggnog no tree no mistletoe no Holly
no nothing this is you know what this is
like this is like if you're gonna make a
crappy pointless repetitive stupid
country song but you never say anything
in the song about blue jeans or pickup
trucks or corn fields like if you're
gonna give us that kind of song then
give us that song don't give us a bad
country song that doesn't even have the
stuff in it that makes it a country song
so now we'd have to get we have a bad
country song that isn't even cut it's
just a bad song it's just a blad generic
song that isn't even country so don't
give us a bad Christmas song that lacks
even the Christmas parts of it because
now we have a bad song that I don't even
know what to do with well apparently we
play it all the time on Christmas I have
no idea why so all the other bad
Christmas songs you can name they're bad
they're stupid they're annoying but they
are Christmas Santa baby I don't know
what's going on in that song I get what
this is like a love song to Santa pretty
weird okay Santa is a what eighteen
hundred year old fat morbidly obese man
who breaks into he's a serial burglar
breaking into people's homes and she's
so that's strange but at least Santa so
you got Santa at least at least there's
at least we've got Santa so there's some
Christmasy stuff going on all right I
actually had more emails I was gonna do
but that I spent 15 minutes on why I
hate wonderful Christmas time so I think
we'll just have to wrap it up there and
hope you guys all have a great weekend
Godspeed
the Matt Walsh show is produced by Sean
Hampton executive producer Jeremy boring
senior producer Jonathan hey supervising
producer Mathis Glover supervising
producer Robert Stirling technical
producer Austin Stephens editor Donovan
Fowler audio mixer Mike Cora Mina the
Matt Walsh show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 20 19
if you prefer facts over feelings aren't
offended by the brutal truth and you can
still laugh at the insanity filling our
national news cycle well tune in to the
Ben Shapiro show we will get a whole lot
of that and much more see you there